hello everybody
we are here and I'm going to review how
you can understand one part of what I
call the Trivium for the vulcan tech
gospel which is snapshot which is the
idea of a pattern when you take a
picture at one of the four cardinal
points namely north east south west of
the pattern what it would possibly look
like so let's just jump into the app
right now so I'm gonna go ahead and
enter my act all right so what we're
gonna do right now is we are going to
learn about these snapshots there are
six total snapshots these instructions
are also in the app but just want to go
over them with you right now
there is tog out oil crops are facing
out there is split out namely the props
are actually separated from one another
the hands are separating one another and
the props are facing out we also have
fog in where the props are together the
hands are together and they both face in
we also have split in namely the hands
are split but the props are facing in
and then finally this sort of last two
tricky ones which is namely tog split
and only your hands are together but the
props are facing opposite direction it's
kind of like that okay and then our last
one is split tog namely your hands are
split but they're facing the same
direction okay with those six snap shots
in two axes we get a total of 36 squares
in our vpg okay so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna go ahead and look at a
couple patterns just to sort of see if
we can understand how maybe you know we
could use them to understand our
patterns better so what we're gonna do
right now is we're actually gonna click
on the club icon up here changing our
prop boom and that will help us see them
a little better so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna start with together same
together same extension so let's go
ahead and take a quick look at that boom
we click that together teh same together
same extension some quick things to
notice namely
that the props are directly overlaid on
top of one another and she don't see two
of them there and they both face out so
for example they're both together out
together out together out together out
mooom and that's a tog same extension
well let's look at a pattern that does
together in like you know both facing in
together on either the X or Y so we go
to the tog in column and let's just go
ahead and go to something like this one
right here okay so this is a tog same
tog same vertical anti spin so we click
that pattern boom here is a tog same tog
same vertical auntie spin nice you can
see they face out tog in tog out target
tog out target nice okay kind of see
that happening there and now what's
really cool and can really help us
understand our patterns is well these
are easy right because the timing
direction of the hands of props are the
same but let's go ahead and move all the
way over to here namely this pattern
which is actually this combination of an
extension and a vertical anti spin and
now you notice that the time and darks
of hands of props is actually different
this is where our snapshots become
particularly helpful just go ahead and
click that pattern and now here we go
you can see that they both phase out on
the y axis now they're talked split out
hog split both facing out
tarek split okay so you can see how
understand these snapshots can really
help sort of place yourself between
quarter motions and yeah so that's kind
of our snapshots all of these patterns
on the vtg are identified by two
distinct snapshots and you so for
example if i clicked on any of these
squares let's go ahead just click there
you can see that it's gonna have a tog
split right here on the y axis and tog
in on the x axis so let's go ahead and
click that just take a quick peek boom
look at that there's tog in tog split
tog in tog split awesome and this is all
of our snapshots and
in the app itself you can access
information about the snapshot
themselves and this is one third of
helping you understand the BTU before we
leave today we're all in the one one I
just want to mention this is 40 patterns
you probably see 36 squares we mentioned
that these four squares have two
patterns each but we also have another
40 which is right here namely I press
this button up here and I got to the 1/3
we also have another 40 when I press
whoops this one so here's another 40 so
that means is 120 patterns in the vtg
which is pretty exciting
now what I'm going to do before we go
I'll give you a little taste of what
we're gonna explore next time is that
we'll transition between the three
patterns namely this one right here that
we just went over this one right here so
tog same talk same extension talk soon
talk same vertical and do spend and talk
same tog op vertical edge spend versus
extension we're gonna transition between
all this using our Tier three sequence
builder what I have to do is I have to
take the pattern see I'm dragging it
right into the bottom oops I'm gonna
take this pattern I'm gonna drag it
right into our sequence builder OOP I'm
gonna take this one and you probably
have realized and say all share the tog
addicts tog out on the y-axis at either
the top or bottom point that we'll be
able to transition our secret skill
builder we'll go into more later has a
lot of options here I'm go to extend the
time so that we can make sure that we
see the pattern and and we're gonna go
ahead and press the eyeball to look at
it boom here we go here's the extension
here it goes and then oh and there's a
vertical line to spend on the toggle
point and then there it goes again
and boom it's a looping pattern and
you'll see it loop right about here boom
here's our extension and this sequence
builder is actually really remarkable
and we'll go over more about this
another time
thank you for watching the vtg mini
tutorial series and please stay tuned
for vtg day July 15th peace